the future of farming a sustainable
whole Farm approach farming has always
been the backbone of human civilization
but as we Face growing challenges like
climate change soil degradation water
scarcity and an increasing global
population the way we Farm must evolve
sustainability in agriculture is no
longer just a trend it's a necessity for
survival today we'll explore the concept
of a whole Farm approach a strategy that
promises not just productivity but also
resilience and long-term environmental
health this approach isn't about making
single changes like planting cover crops
or switching to organic fertilizer it's
about treating your farm as a connected
system where every action benefits the
whole let's dive into what this means
and how adopting the system can set
Farmers up for a brighter future a whole
Farm approach looks at the farm as an
entire ecosystem where crops soil
livestock water machinery and energy all
work together to achieve
sustainability this isn't just smarter
farming it's a balanced holistic method
that ensures the farm remains productive
while protecting natural resources at
its heart the whole Farm approach aligns
with three key pillars of
sustainability environmental
sustainability protecting the land water
and
biodiversity economic sustainability
ensuring profitability through better
efficiency and higher yields three
social sustainability supporting food
security and vibrant rural communities
by embracing this strategy farmers can
adapt to Modern challenges and create a
prosperous Future Ready Farm all while
conserving resources and fostering
ecological balance to fully implement
the whole Farm approach farmers can
adopt several sustainable practices here
are some of the most effective methods
crop rotation involves alternating the
crops grown in a field over Seasons or
years instead of planting the same crop
repeatedly a farmer May plant legumes
one year cereals the next and cover
crops afterward
benefits improves soil fertility by
naturally replenishing nutrients breaks
the cycle of pests and diseases
increases yield potential cover crops
are planted between main crop Cycles to
cover and protect the soil from erosion
enhance soil organic matter and suppress
weeds they also fix nitrogen in the soil
if luminous plants are used reducing the
need for chemical
fertilizers
benefits prevent soil erosion by keeping
the top soil intact enhances water
retention reducing irrigation needs
supports microbial activity fostering
soil Health instead of solely relying on
synthetic pesticides IPM encourages a
combination of physical biological and
chemical methods to manage pests
benefits reduces chemical use and
farming expenses
encourages natural Predators like birds
or beneficial insects minimizes harm to
the environment and pollinators
livestock can play a vital role in
sustainable farming for example grazing
animals can manage weeds naturally
fertilize Fields with their manure and
help cycle nutrients back into the soil
benefits provides natural fertilizers
reducing the need for synthetic ones
enables the farm to scale up production
sustainably by utilizing multi-purpose
land use efficient water management is
critical techniques like drip irrigation
rainwater harvesting and precise
watering schedules can minimize Water
waste
benefits helps Farms operate with
minimal Water Resources protects local
water bodies from overuse or
contamination installing solar panels
wind turbines or using bioga systems can
help reduce Planet Waring greenhouse gas
emissions while cutting energy costs
benefits reduces dependency on fossil
fuels makes the farm self-reliant and
resilient during power
shortages technology is transforming
agriculture with advancements like
artificial intelligence drones and the
internet of things iot farmers can now
Monitor and improve their operations
with unmatched Precision iot devices can
measure and track soil Health moisture
levels and weather patterns in real time
allowing better decision- making
automated Machinery helps an optimal
plan
watering and fertilizing while
minimizing resource
wastage artificial intelligence can
process vast amounts of farm data to
predict the best planting schedules
Harvest times or even market trends it
can also suggest crop varieties suited
to changing weather conditions drones
are becoming indispensable for
monitoring crops for pest infestations
or
dehydration applying fertilizers or
pesticides precisely saving resources
and preventing over application
these Technologies don't just make
farming more efficient they ease the
burden on Farmers by automating tedious
tasks and optimizing resource use the
whole Farm approach isn't just a theory
it's already creating a positive impact
for Farmers worldwide one farmer in
India switched to crop rotation and
cover crops which naturally restored the
soil fertility on his land over 5 years
he saw a 20% rise in productivity
without applying additional chemical
fertilizers
in the United States Farmers utilizing
iot devices to track soil Health
significantly reduced water use during
drought years saving both resources and
money while still achieving consistent
yields these success stories Inspire
confidence in a system that boost yields
while protecting the planet for future
Generations sustainable farming
practices do more than protect the
environment they also make Financial
sense here's how lower input costs by
shifting to Renewable Energy natural
fertilizers and water efficiency systems
Farms can reduce operational
costs higher yields healthier soil and
integrated Pest Management lead to more
resilient
crops Diversified income streams
incorporating AGR forestry ecotourism or
organic farming can add new Revenue
paths long-term productivity practices
like no till farming and Soil
Conservation ensure that the land
remains fertile and productive for
decades to come with growing consumer
demand for sustainably grown produce
farmers who Embrace these practices
position themselves to earn premium
prices in the market sustainability
extends well beyond profits by adopting
a whole Farm approach Farmers contribute
to critical environmental and social
efforts protecting biodiversity through
natural ecosystems and pollinator
friendly practices reducing greenhouse
gas emissions improving carbon
sequestration using cover crops renew
able energy enhancing Community
resilience by supporting rural jobs and
improving food security through better
yields together these efforts align with
global sustainability goals ensuring a
healthier planet for all transitioning
to a whole Farm approach may seem
daunting but it doesn't have to happen
all at once here are some actionable
steps to get started start small Begin
by implementing one or two practices
such as cover crops or crop rotation
monitor the result results and expand
gradually use available technology look
into affordable iot devices or Precision
farming tools that fit your budget they
can maximize efficiency three seek
resources research grants government
programs or organizations offering
support for sustainable Farms join a
community connect with other like-minded
Farmers either locally or online to
learn from their experiences and share
insights sustainable farming is the
future and the whole Farm approach isn't
just about surviving today's challenges
it's about thriving tomorrow by thinking
of the farm as a connected ecosystem and
adopting Innovative Technologies and
practices farmers can build a resilient
profitable and environmentally friendly
operation the role of farmers has never
been more crucial you are the stewards
of the land and with a sustainable
Vision you can leave a legacy of health
and abundance for future Generations
start small be patient and invest in
this journey it's worth it for you your
community and the planet let's cultivate
a future where productivity and
sustainability grow hand inand subscribe
share and like for more informative
videos thanks for watching the video and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more watching